they're critically acclaimed Steven
Spielberg movie the post highlights the
historic events surrounding the leaking
of the Pentagon Papers by former defense
department analyst Daniel Ellsberg the
movie dramatizes the Washington Post
decision to publish the top-secret
documents which detailed America's
decades-long involvement in the conflict
in Vietnam top officials including
President Johnson's first Defense
Secretary Robert McNamara were
implicated in the resulting scandal but
it was Daniel Ellsberg who alerted the
press to what was really going on there
actor Matthew Reese plays Ellsberg in
the post the study had 47 volumes I
slipped out a couple at a time to be
months to copy at all what the hell well
we were all former government guys top
clearance all that McNamara wanted
academic stead the chance to examine
what had happened he would say to us let
the chips fall where they may
I think guilt was a bigger motivating
than courage met American lies well as
an arrest but I don't think he saw what
was coming what we'd fine but it didn't
take him long to figure well first all
to figure out if the public ever saw
these papers they would turn against the
war let the chips fall where they may
indeed Matthew Reese welcome to the
table thank you very much so Time
magazine says this about you you played
the role with a muted matter-of-fact
intensity wow I think I said that talk
about mr. Ellsberg and how pivotal he
was in history tell us about him
incredibly so I I was ashamed to say I
didn't know as much as I should know
about what he did we forgive you I thank
you he was a pioneer of his time in his
whistleblowing if you will and and had
such a clarity of intention about the
wrongdoing this war was doing not just
to the United States but the country of
Vietnam as well and then you meet the
real Daniel Ellsberg who's now 80
something yeah I think he's a yes we'll
say 80 something okay released his new
book so what struck you most about him
what did you want to say to him what
struck me most is how his his
campaigning is tireless he still is
ardent and as for
as he was then as he is he is now as he
was then about this sort of you know the
wrongdoings in in this world I I was the
more I learned the more I was staggered
by his bravery really that he knew the
consequences and this is a man who was
working was a former marine working for
the government when that event go on for
and you know he was a true patriot but
they just saw the wrongdoing and says I
can't live with a true patriot as you
say too cuz he was working for Rand and
the RAND Corporation and here he saw a
study that had covered four different
presidents about what had gone into the
decision-making of Vietnam all you know
warts and all
yes warts it on here was buried and he
took them out serendipitously and starts
photocopying and in the movie he has
colleagues photocopying the volumes but
in fact in real life who was
photocopying the Pentagon Papers
he took his children along when how old
were they I love that one detail or I'm
not quite sure there was something 11
and eight yeah they were young and they
were kind of cutting the tops off the
tops you know it said top-secret they
were helping him sliced it was what got
the feffy I ultimately on to him was
that they you know he was divorced at
the time I think children went back told
the grandmother what was happening well
like what we to have you been doing with
father and they said Oh cutting the tops
and says top-secret and she went grandma
grandma dropped the dime on him yes
you met him so when you met him are you
taking notes or is there something he
tells you that says here's how you play
me well yeah so I had a thousand
questions from primarily was my first
obvious stupid question was house how
scared were you and he said it wasn't
that scared and that's when I realized
they had this clarity of intention about
what he was doing and his conviction was
was without question because he he'd
seen you know what the what the body
count was coming back to the United
States and how it was affecting you know
Vietnamese both civilian and we've
talked about Steven Spielberg the
director of this and he said when he
read this script he wanted to make it
immediately and he did I mean the post
the whole production time I think was a
just about a year what was it like
working with Spielberg terrifying
terrifying you'd say everything you want
and then know
you know the worst thing in the world
all to some extent when it happens
because he's this it's like acting in
front of God he's like an icon and et
was the first movie you saw that's why I
think that's kind of cool so it's sort
of six degrees of separation then you're
with him but I have to talk to you about
the Americans I love this show please
don't turn page Russian who's living in
America you guys are spies yes but your
your character is so brutal and so
ruthless yet we still care for this guy
why I was gonna say something very
boastful then but I don't know the
writing is very bothered yes yes the
writing is so good no I think what's
great about the show is that it does
humanize these these these people not
just that those in the intelligence
community then it's the last season - it
is it is thankfully but bittersweet you
ready ladies thank you so much thanks so